ومعي الزميل خالد الغرابلي خالد الو مرحبا
بك معنا خالد كما تابعنا الرئيس الامريكي
في كييف اليوم للاعلان عن مساعدات جديده
مساعده عسكريه جديده
لاوكرانيا يبدو في الكواليس ان هناك مخاوف
امريكيه من دور صيني اكبر في هذه الحرب
لنقل ان الظاهر في الصوره هو رساله
امريكيه بايدن يريد ان يقول للاوكرانيين
ولروس قبل الاوكرانيين انه قبل عام كانت
هناك طائرات روسيه تقصف كانت هناك دبابات
روسيه تتجه باتجاه كيف والامريكيون تدخلوا
وحشدوا العالم لمساعده اوكرانيا وبفضل ذلك
لم تسقط كييف واليوم بعد مرور عام على هذه
الحرب الامريكيون يقولون انهم دائما
حاضرون
في دعمك طبعا الحديث هذا هو هي بالنسبه لي
في تقديره هي الرساله الاهم من جانب
الامريكي اما الحديث عن 500 مليون دولار
المساعدات او بعض الاسلحه لم يكن بيضا في
حاجه الى الذهاب الى اوكرانيا حتى يعلن عن
ذلك الولايات المتحده اهم مقدم للمساعدات
العسكريه لاوكرانيا هذا في الظاهر لكن في
الكواليس واضح ان هناك مخاوف امريكيه
مخاوف من ماذا هناك مخاوف امريكيه من
العديد من النقاط يعني هناك مخافه امريكيه
من احتمال تدخل الصين على الخط بلنكن ابلغ
مسؤول صيني كبير من هو عضو من اللجنه
المركزيه في القياده السياسيه الصينيه
الحزب الشيوعي
واخبره ان الولايات المتحده معلومات بان
الصين تدرس امكانيه امداد روسيا بالذخيره
وحتى السلاح ماذا يعني لدينا معلومات في
الغالب كلمه لدينا معلومات هي معلومات
استخباراتيه الاستخبارات الامريكيه حصلت
على معلومات تفيد بذلك
رغم ان الجانب الامريكي لم يكشف طبيعه هذه
المعلومات الذي التي لديه لكي يستطيع ان
يتحدث عن احتمال تغيير الدور الصيني مع
العلم ان الجانب الامريكي منذ شهور طويله
وهو يراقب التحرك الصيني ويعلم جيدا ان ما
قدمه الصينيون حتى الان ربما سترات واقيه
استخدمها الروس في اوكرانيا وفرض عقوبات
على بعض الشركات الصينيه لكن كانوا يعلمون
ان اصل لم تصل الى حد تقديم لا ذخائر ولا
اسلحه ولن تحرق هذه العقوبات المفروضه على
روسيا وبالتالي كانوا في مامن لكن اليوم
الامريكيون يقولون ان لديهم معلومات
بامكانيه حدوث ذلك وهذا طبعا بالنسبه
للجانب الامريكي في غايه الخطوره لماذا في
غايه الخطوره اولا لان هدم يعني اطاله امد
الحرب استنزاف موارد حلف الاطلسي
والولايات المتحده وبالتالي اطاله امد
الحرب ربما لبعد الانتخابات الامريكيه
التي ستجري في نوف من العام المقبل
وبالتالي هناك احتمال ان يصل رئيس جديد
للولايات المتحده وقد يكون جمهوري غير
متحمس لاستمرار تقديم هذا الدعم وهذا
سيكون له تداعيات خطيره على سير الدعم
الامريكي وهو هذا الدعم هو العمود الفقري
لمساعده الاوكرانيين على مستوى الدولي اذا
هذا على الناحيه العملاتيه ان اردتي لكن
النحل استراتيجيه ايضا
هناك شعور امريكي بان الامور تتغير على
مستوى العالم يعني يبدو ان هناك تحالف ان
صدقت هذه المعلومات الاستخباراتيه التي
يتحدث عنها الامريكيون انصدقت هذه
المعلومات يعني ان هناك نوع من الحلف الذي
يتشكل روسيا ايران من خلال الطائرات
المسيره التي تقدم كوريا الشماليه التي
تقدم الذخيره بحسب الولايات المتحده
واليوم قد تكون ايضا اصيل مع العلم ان
الصين تنفي حتى الان هذه المعلومات كل ذلك
امام جهه اخرى الولايات المتحده والدول
الاوروبيه الغرب وبالتالي يظهر انه على
البعد الاستراتيجي الاوسع هناك تحالفات
يقتربان من المواجهه ان اردتي ليس فقط
بتصريحات وبعض العقوبات الاقتصاديه لكن
ايضا بممارسات عسكريه هذا بالنسبه لمخاوف
الامريكيه لكن هناك ايضا نوع من عدم
الارتياح الاوكراني لانه حتى الان حتى وان
سمعنا كلمات الترحيب الاوكراني بزياره
بايدن لكن في النهايه اوكرانيا لم تحصل
بعد على الطائرات التي تنتظرها والجميع
ينتظر الموافقه امريكيه للسماح بارسال مثل
هذه الطائرات لان ارسال الطائرات يعني
تصعيد يعني رده فعل روسيه وان لم تكن هناك
حمايه امريكيه الجميع سيخشى رده الفعل
الروسيه ولن يقدم احد على تقديم هذه
الطائرات حتى الدبابات التي وعدت بها
اوكرانيا هناك تاخير في ايصال هذه
الدبابات هناك الحاح من الاوكرانيين
بالاسراع بالايصال هذه الدبابات وطبعا
هناك حاجه ايضا لذخيره التي لم تتوفر لكن
هذا سبب تقني وليس سبب سياسي اردت لكن خلف
الصوره التي نراها لبيض في اوكرانيا هناك
وضع غير مريح اردت في الكواليس طيب خالد
بكينا نفت رسميا اليوم هل لها مصلحه في
المشاركه في هذه الحرب بشكل او باخر اصيل
ليس لها مصلحه في التصعيد مع الولايات
المتحده تماما ليس لها مصلحه في التصعيد
مع الصين لكن في النهايه الصين هي منزعجه
من الولايات المتحده منزعجه بسبب موضوع
المناطيس التي اسقطتها الولايات المتحده
وتقول انها مناطير تجسس صينيه منزعجه لان
هناك تحالف عسكري اخذ شكل جديد مع اليابان
حتى وان كان هناك علاقات وثيقه جدا
لتحميل اليابان لكن هناك اليوم
شراكه عسكريه اكبر حتى تسمح للولايات
المتحده لاستخدام بعض الجزر اليابانيه في
مواجهه اي محاوله صينيه عسكريه لاعاده
السيطره على تايوان على سبيل المثال
هناك الموقف الامريكي من تايوان كوريا
الجنوبيه التي تريد ان يكون لها كلمه في
استخدام سلاح نووي على اراضيها في مواجهه
اي مخاطر محتمله مع كوريا الشماليه حليفه
الصين ومع الصين طبعا هناك هذا الحلف
المهمه التي تبنيه الولايات المتحده مع
استراليا
في
المملكه البريطانيه بريطانيا في مواجهه
الصين اذن التحرك طبعا خلاف المناوشات
الموجوده في بحر الصين بين الولايات
المتحده والصين اذن الصين تشعر ان
الولايات المتحده تجسد عمليا على الارض
شراكه عسكريه متزايده مع حلفاء قريبين
جغرافيا من حدودها وهذا يزعجهم الى حد
كبير ضيفي الى ذلك عقوبات اقتصاديه تفرضها
الولايات المتحده على شركات صينيه كل ذلك
يزعج الصينيين وربما يريدون ربما يرغب
الصينيون في الرد لكن بشكل غير مباشر
ازعاج الامريكيين وبالتالي ان كان هناك
الصين مره اخرى الصين في رسميا لكن ان كان
هناك بعض الشركات التي يمكن ان تقدم شيء
ما بشكل سري وفي محاوله لاخفائه كما تقول
الولايات المتحده ان الصينيين يدرسون هذا
الموضوع
سيحاول الصينيون بكل طريقه ممكنه الابتعاد
رسميا عن اي محاوله مثل هذه لان الرساله
هي المفروض او المرغوب ربما ان تكون نريد
ان نزعج الولايات المتحده نريد ان نهدد
باننا من الممكن ان نكون حلف مع روسيا لكن
رسميا نحن لسنا حلفاء مع الروس ضد احد
ونحن هنا حتى لطرح افكار سياسيه تسمح بحل
هذا الموضوع بشكل سلمي اذا من مصلحه ليس
لها مصلحه مباشره لكن قد يكون من المهم
لها ارسال رساله الى اجانب الامريكي
بطريقه لا تصل الى حد المواجهه المباشره
مع الامري كيه شكرا لك خالد على كل هذه
التوضيحات